On TikTok. Do it.
Where is it though? On top,
up high.
Put your hand in for the top.
No, it's not.
I didn't even have to hold. That's the heart.
Chambers of the heart is. That's where it pumps blood.
Inside that, it's the heart right there.
Inside the heart would be the blood pump.
And then there's an artery that would take the.
The blood around the chicken's body. Isn't that cool?
Yeah. Someone from the chicken.
Isn't that cool? That thing,
that black thing reprises blood. That.
That blood. That black thing is a blood clot.
Cause it died and the blood started clotting up
cause it had nowhere else to go anymore.
Just. Just touch it right here and see what the foul feels like.